okay so now we have those combination of
c and iy and we're going to start
bringing it a little closer to the kihon
so iido the way that we use the C and II
is either on the inward spiral or on the
outward spiral and again the reason why
I only have those two is because I got a
spiral rotate my lower to den and the
hands are what moves
the lower tonen it's not it's not I
don't ever use my waist I don't do that
okay so you have to have your Palm Point
as we mentioned okay and the first one
will'll do a Coq projection this time I
won't just do it wherever I am going to
aim it in his Center
okay and we won't let him let
go okay so you have one C you and now
you're going to use that GR grip in the
in the I key you you have to use the
grip in the I key move his Center to get
the other spiral so it's not that I tilt
him and then he comes back and I turn
this
no I'm moving his Center boom and moving
his
Center and then your final copu so again
in boom move him
boom
adhere
[Music]
you
okay here we
go so all the skill sets you've been
developing you have in here
okay so you have your grounding he's
pushing so it's the same grounding okay
drill number two in both the K and the I
set you're doing the same thing okay you
have your cyu projection that you do
always so boom but this time you're
aiming it and you I've given it shape
okay I'm not using the simplistic or the
simplified linear so I'm in he can't
push throughout the movement he can't
push me over okay it's not that I go
here he can push I'm not y doing that
yielding I'm doing the catch on his
Center so he can't at any point push and
knock me over and then I will go in
Center then I'm going to do the same
adhesions I'm just doing it in his grip
so I'm moving him in boom
and then one more coke
you so I project him boom oh you're
going to keep your grip
down boom I move him oh I'm moving him
he should be all the way in the back
back there then one more cook you from
on on his head
boom of course whenever you're in
Wasa we're emptying the qua so the quaw
go do you want to get that
[Music]
going your arms are as relaxed as they
were
before
okay so in this in the standing
drills you catch the center with your
weight shift okay you don't catch it in
your hands right and so your arm this
young contention point in this Sagal
playe moves back as I move to the the
back leg okay so boom that's what
catches
it same thing
here I don't want it to C I don't do
this we're not doing this oh I don't
catch it with my arm moving my quaw
moves the quaw moves the quaw does the
change so when I take my quaw this way
this arm moov towards me so look where I
am and then watch his PL his or chest
plotted in space when I go here it comes
forward and that's all I
want so I just open and close my
[Music]
clock and again I ignore him I just do
the
exercise
okay don't move your elbows in and
out go